what would you tell that 30 year old 20
year old Jay to give him the courage to
do as you've done to go into the
impossible you know it's really easy for
young people and certainly that was true
for me to think that everyone else
around you especially the older people
who have distinguished careers know
everything and that they can tell you
you're on to something or not onto
something I tell that 20 year old a 30
year old that's doing science you know
no one really has all the answers and if
they're telling you no it's not because
they know no they just you know that's
the knee-jerk reaction almost everything
is wrong you need to have some
confidence in yourself you might be
right and all the old guys around you
right here might be wrong that's
certainly possible that's how science
advances Brian is when but gray hairs
like me get proven wrong and I think
that's a really good thing
foreign